tom is with us in New Jersey hey Tom how
are ya hey Dave great so how are you
doing today
great how can we help Joe question for
you and I think when I was on hold I
might have heard you can see already but
62 years old I have about 1.6 in my 401k
plan have about 22 thousand dollars in
credit card bills and I want to get rid
of them so they just won't go away
so would you recommend in that situation
to take it out of the 401k plan or is
there going to be a tax implication you
know you're an if I do that oh you'll
pay taxes on whatever you take out you
won't have a penalty on it because of
the cares Act how do you have 1.6
million dollars in your 401k and don't
have any other money it's just I've been
working for a company for 40 years so
I've been putting into my I don't have
any other savings plan
I have other stock I have about 2.5 and
used that that I have use that use that
instead they're gonna be my other
question okay okay but if there's still
a tax cheat on that or is that all based
on it might be a tax on but it's not in
a retirement account
I wouldn't yeah I mean it's it's six
month none of the other mathematically
for me it's just the the holy grail is
your 401ks what got you here I mean
you're worth a couple million dollars
congratulations touchdown
you killed it way to go I'm assuming you
did not inherit this since it's all in a
401k right absolutely not yeah you've
earned this through your working
lifetime how old are you you said 62 I
think you kill yeah what do you do for a
living
maybe for more in sales into it and yeah
you sound like an everyday millionaire
so you didn't inherit the money you
simply earned it and saved it trek and
now you're worth a couple million
dollars plus way to go I just want to
get I want to get these credit-card
bills away yeah and what I do retire in
three years I can enjoy that's so I mean
they just sell some of that stalking
yeah I would here's the trick now okay
the credit cards are not the problem
they're the symptom
so we have to we have to plug the hole
went to plug the leak and the leak is
number one way we plug the leaks would
cut up the credit cards get a debit card
so you only spend money you have from
this point forward it'll do everything
your credit card will do except put you
into debt and the second thing you do is
you get on a written plan you've been so
good with money and just the fine tuning
would be the written plan is going to
give you a sense of power Rachel when
you're talking about the budget you talk
about the power yeah absolutely I mean I
think a lot of people assume a budget
limits your freedom but it doesn't it
gives you freedom and so instead of
weighing down with this twenty two
thousand dollars in credit card debt if
you're on a budget yours in a debit card
there's none of that weight so it
actually gives you the freedom to spend
money and not have to be guilty about it
and I have to question it it's all right
there and and getting into that habit I
think is is going to be key considering
you will be retiring in about three
years that you make the retirement that
you have already in your 401k and the
stocks that let that go even further in
retirement versus just feeling like oh
I'm gonna cash it out and just and go
crazy that budget and getting that habit
in no it's done an amazing amazing
22,000 it's not a big deal but it is
symptomatic and so if I were in your
shoes I'd cut the cards and I live on a
plan the plan doesn't mean you can't do
anything when plan means you can do
whatever you decide to do except going
to that it was just sloppy it was an
intellectual laziness that allowed you
to stumble into this little bit of debt
and it is a little bit of debt relative
to the fact that you're worth two
million dollars so you have done
amazingly well sir congratulations